I had you guys send me some of your best
would you rather scenarios so I'm going
to be answering a few of those would you
rather stay overnight in the Evil Dead
cabin or take part in a brutal saw trap
trial I would prefer to stay in the Evil
Dead cabin just because I think there's
a better chance at survival we've seen
in the Evil Dead movies that if you are
resourceful then there is a chance you
can survive at the end and I think I am
the type of person who would be able to
survive an evil dead movie as for saw
it's really kind of 50 50 as to whether
it's survivable or not some of the traps
do have an actual solution and are
winnable but others are just death traps
with no way out that being said I do
think it would be more fun to be in a
saw trap a lot of times when I'm
watching the movies I am thinking about
solutions that the characters might not
have thought of and how I would get out
of it so if it was a survivable trap or
survival was guaranteed then I would
probably go with a saw trap as being
more fun but in terms of survivability I
would have to go with the Evil Dead
cabin if you want to see me address more
would you rather scenarios leave a few
of them in the comments